You will not believe what is happening
right now because Satan is just coming
right out in the open under the guise of
science under the scientific
institutions. Check this out. This is
from science alert. This is a really
wellreceived scientific website that
says scientists identify how young blood
reverses aging in human skin cells. So
think about that. We have abortion
clinics all over the country and you
know people always want to justify it by
saying oh life of the mother or incest
or rape and all these things. I've
looked at the polls. You can look at the
percentages of why abortions are
performed. Less than 1% less than 1%
that was even lower than I expected are
because of those things. Incest, rape,
life of the mother. The majority the
majority of why abortions are performed
is for convenience. And that was
literally the terminology used. You
know, oops, I got pregnant. You know, I
I I was doing what God told me not to
do. I was having sex outside of wedlock
and all these things and I needed
abortion. See, if we do it God's way, we
don't need abortion clinics. We don't
need STD treatments. We don't need all
kinds of stuff because God's way is the
perfect way. Back to the subject here.
It says young blood reverses aging in
human skin cells. This is interesting.
It says the idea of taking blood from
the young to rejuvenate the elderly is
is getting an increasing amount of
attention from scientists and a new
study has shown how some of the youthful
properties of our skin can be restored
with this kind of blood swap. Uh let's
see. It says, "Further analysis
identified 55 different proteins that
were being produced by the bone marorrow
in response to the young blood. Seven of
which are known to be linked to the
process important to youthful skin like
cell renewal and collagen production.
These proteins could be key to
understanding the effects of the young
blood and bone marrow. Though there's
plenty of work to do yet, researchers
need to get this tested in living
humans, not just isolated cells in the
lab. They've already been doing this on
rats. We identified several proteins
that might be responsible factors to
rejuvenate the skin and our system.
Write the researchers. Further studies
are needed to further validate our
identified proteins in the context of
systemic skin rejuvenation and aging.
The concept of blood having the power to
extend life and restore youth has been
around for centuries, inspiring the
first vampire tales, but there's an
increasing amount of evidence that it
could have actual scientific potential.
Okay, I don't even need to read anymore
because this is insane. This is um you
know the fountain of youth, the vampires
who just never age. And why? Because
they're always biting a victim, right?
usually a virgin woman uh that they have
to drink the blood of and they're
saying, "Hey, there's actually some
validity to this." I'm thinking of the
movies Twilight where the girl is
falling in love with a vampire and a
werewolf, both who are literally demons,
and these movies came out and got all
these teenage girls like into falling in
love with demons. And oh, I wonder which
one she's going to pick. She should
really take Jacob or whatever his name
was. It was all these, it was like team
Edward and team Jacob. I can't believe
it, man. But this even got on uh Yahoo
News and they were covering the story as
well. And so this is a real scientific
study right now. Here it is on National
Library of Medicine. Uh let's see. It
says young plasma rejuvenates blood DNA
methylation profile extends mean
lifespan and improves physical
appearance in old rats. So they've
already tested this taken the I guess
the DNA or blood of a young rat put in
an old rat and the old rat is getting
younger. Not just like stopping the
aging process but actually reversing it.
There's this term called revelation of
the method. Revelation of the method is
a concept suggesting that those in
power, the elites, right, often referred
to as the elite, subtly or indirectly
disclose their actions, intentions, or
methods to the public even while
manipulating public perception or
extracting consent without awareness. It
is often tied to the ideas about
predictive programming and and implied
consent. So remember also just like the
vampire tale, a vampire cannot come in
unless they're invited in, right? They
can stand outside the door. They can
stand outside the window, but you have
to let them in. That comes from the
demonic world. That comes from Satan is
not allowed into your life. Demons are
not allowed into our lives until we give
them permission in some way, shape, or
form. Whether that's drug use, alcohol,
Ouija boards, tarot cards,
dreamcatchers, yoga, bad music, bad
movies, bad video games, all kinds of
stuff that we culturally accept today,
fornication, all those things that we do
today that seem normal are gateways to
letting in demons into our life. But if
we were to never touch those things,
Satan does not have access to our life.
So how does he do it? uses this
platform, this mass media platform, and
he puts it in predictive programming. He
puts it in the science realm where it's
like, "Oh, we could use young babies
blood to rejuvenate people." And we're
like, "Wow, that's super cool." Like, we
already have abortion clinics anyways.
Don't throw the babies away. Let's just
use their blood to help us stay
youthful. This sounds like a satanic
sci-fi movie. like we're going to
basically farm babies to take their
blood and keep ourselves youthful. What
if what if women just started doing
that? Get impregnated on purpose, abort
the baby, take the baby's blood, and
ingest it or whatever they're doing with
it to stay youthful forever. This is
insane. This is so satanic. I can't even
believe we're talking about this as
real. But Revelation 12:12 said,
"Therefore rejoice ye heavens and ye
dwell and ye that dwell in them. Woe to
the inhabiters of the earth, that's us,
and of the sea, for the devil is come
down unto you having great wrath because
he knoweth that he have but a short
time." Satan knows his time is up. We're
seeing all the signs. If if deceived
humans can see the signs of the time so
clearly that Satan is going to
impersonate Christ soon, Christ is right
around the corner to return, then Satan
also knows. He He knows the Bible
backwards and forwards. He knows the
prophecies better than we do. He knows
he has a short time. So, it's like
gloves are off. He's putting it all out
in your face and we're going to just
accept it without question. We're not
going to push back on this scientific
thing, right? Oh, this is a awesome
research. Great. We can all live
forever. Nobody's even going to push
back on taking the blood of innocent
children to keep your youth. Um, I don't
want to jump to conclusions, but all of
a sudden, this like just happened
recently. Everyone is noticing that
people in Hollywood are reversing their
age. They're like age reversing. the
Kardashians's mom. She was 66 here and
she looks decent for a 66 year old
woman. But now at 69 6 7 8 9 3 years
later she literally looks like she's 20
years younger. 25 years younger. I mean
if I if I was judging by this picture
how old this lady is, I would say mid4s.
She's 69 years old. Check out Mariah
Carey. This picture was 10 years ago and
this is her now. I mean, I've looked at
my driver's license picture of 10 years
and I'm shocked at how much I age in 10
years, but Hollywood is somehow defying
this.
Oh, this is the most shocking of all.
Martha Stewart, guys, I've never in my
life, I'm just going to get candid right
here. I've never in my life looked at
Martha Stewart and thought, "Wow, she's
a beautiful woman." I'm just being
honest. I'm not trying to be mean. I'm
just saying she's not my type. I would
never look at her and think Martha
Stewart is a beautiful woman, but look
at this. That's Martha Stewart. She is
80 years old. She's 84 right now. This
is crazy. How can an 84 year old woman
look like this? Again, I would say she's
she looks like late 40s, possibly early
50s. She's looking really good even at
early 50s.
And so here's a website that was
pointing out like 15 celebrities that
look like they're aging backwards. I
mean, look at 37 years old. Madonna at
37,
she looks like Hillary Clinton or
something. I mean, she looks like she's
in her 50s. And now at 63 years old, I
mean, she's got like porcelain skin. I
mean, she
it looks a little fake. I mean, there's
some parts to her that look like
definitely was some work done, fillers
or something like that. But this is
insane. Used to uh back when I was
seeing people have work done, you could
always tell their eyebrows were always
up like this, like just pulled back. You
know, the skin was stretched back where
you couldn't even have relaxed eyebrows.
But now,
Beyonce, look at her. 28, 40 years old.
This is crazy. So, the question is, how
are they doing it? There's a lot of
stuff going around. If you've been in
the conspiracy theory rabbit hole like I
have since 2012, um there's a lot of
ideas about some things. I don't even
want to say certain words because I know
that YouTube is just infamous for taking
down videos, for shadow banning videos
if you talk about certain things. But it
sounds like adrenaline and it sounds
like Google Chrome and you put them
together and that's what people say
these people are doing. Now, that sounds
like way out there, right? Like, why
would anyone participate in such a sick
act? Well, remember Satan uh was out
there with Jesus when he was fasting in
the wilderness. Satan said, "Bow to me
and I'll give you all the kingdoms of
the world." Jesus didn't say, "No, it's
already mine. You can't give it to me
because I own it." Jesus calls Satan the
god of this world. Satan owns this
world. And Jesus says, "What profits a
man to gain the whole world and lose his
very soul. So it is possible to make a
deal with the devil to sell your soul to
the devil and say, "I'll do whatever you
ask me to do. I'll be your puppet as
long as I get to uh look beautiful, be
famous, rich, and live like a god on
this earth." And look at people like
Taylor Swift who literally like I've
never seen one person on the cover of
every single magazine. I've never seen
somebody plastered so much as I have
Taylor Swift in the past couple years.
And it makes you wonder how do you get
to that level of success? She's the
richest female on earth right now from
what I understand. At least music artist
I guess. Richest music artist right now.
And these people, they always look
beautiful, always look young, always
rich, and and a lot of them are openly
saying, "Hey, you don't get to this
point unless you sell out." And Cat
Williams is exposing it. Uh Dave
Chappelle, there's a lot of people who
are exposing this industry and they're
painted to look like crazies. But I
believe it. I believe that to get to
this level of success in Satan's
kingdom, you have to work for him. I
mean, that's there's nothing really
crazy about that when you think about it
biblically. Um, some of these people are
openly telling you that they consume
blood. Check out what Megan Fox says.
>> I guess drank each other's blood might
mislead people or like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like Game of Thrones drinking each
other's blood. It's just a few drops,
but
>> it's just a few drops, guys. It's not
like we're consuming a whole cup of
blood. Why is she even like trying to
sugarcoat this? And that's what's crazy.
It's like, uh, you know, people say we
drink each other's blood. I guess that's
kind of the wrong idea. It's It's just a
few drops, guys. Look at This is crazy.
Why do they do it? Why? Listen what she
says.
>> Yes, we do consume each other's blood on
occasion for ritual purposes.
>> Just for ritual purposes. So tell me if
I came to you and I said, "Hey, is there
uh any kind of religion out there where
you consume blood for ritual purposes?"
What would you say? What would your
first answer be? Oh yeah, Satanism.
Right. Uh but she's like, "You know
what? I'm not a Satanist. I'm not into
the Illuminati. Like I've never been
offered that. If there was an
Illuminati, I'd probably be offered
that, right? Because I'm Megan Fox." Um,
but then in the same breath she's like,
"Oh, I I read tarot cards all the time
and I I drink Machine Gun Kelly's
blood." And she talks about how he like
cuts his chest open with glass and says,
"Take my soul." I don't know if she says
it in this clip right here or what
>> only it is used for a reason and it is
controlled where it's like, "Let's shed
a few drops of blood and each drink it."
He's much more haphazard and hectic and
chaotic where he's willing to just like
cut his chest open with broken glass and
be like, "Take my soul."
>> And she doesn't think he's like insane.
Like she's still with him. Like that
silly machine gun Kelly just slices his
chest right opens. Take my soul. And
like, oh, I love him so much. Right.
This is this is insanity. How can we
glorify these people? How can we idolize
these people and say, "Oh, I love Megan
Fox. She's such a great actress. Um,
she's a witch. She's a bloodrinking
tarot card reading witch. And there's
there's no other way to say it, but
that's what she is. And so, look at uh
Machine Gun Kelly right here on page
six.com. This is not a conspiracy theory
website. So, he was wearing these
earrings that look like hypodermic
needles and uh they're saying maybe it's
Megan Fox's blood that they're they're
saying it could possibly be Megan Fox's
blood. says he later revealed that the
Transformers actress Megan Fox had
gifted him a drop of her blood to wear
in a necklace she was when she was
traveling. So they're already wearing
each other's blood on necklaces on
earrings. And listen, look what he says.
Look, this is his post. This is his post
on Instagram. It says he proudly showed
off the accessory on Instagram. Look
what he said. Devils in the details with
a drop of blood and a devil. So, it's
not a big, you know, leap of conclusions
to say, "Hey, he's a devil worshipper.
He drinks blood. He cuts his chest open
and says, "Consume my blood or consume
my soul or whatever." Uh, he's a devil
worshipper. Is that like a a big leap in
logic when he's literally saying the
devil's in the details? It's right in
your face, right? This is the revelation
of the method. That's what they do. They
put it in your face. It's It's like
reverse psychology. Put it in your face
so you won't believe that it's real.
Because when you show people this,
they'd be like, "If that was real, they
wouldn't openly say it." Well, yeah,
they do. And you still deny it. You're
still in denial when they put it right
in your face. The the the best way to
hide something is right in front of your
face. And it's it's like it happens
everywhere. Uh listen to what Sandra
Bulock said.
But what is it?
>> It is an extraction from a um a a piece
of skin uh that came from a young person
um far far away and they somehow figured
out how to extract
>> it's for skin from a Korean baby. It's
like it's
>> that's what it is.
>> I Okay.
>> Who comes up with this? So Sandra Bulock
is putting foreskin of what kind of
baby? A Chinese baby or something on her
face to stay young and youthful. It
might be more than just foreskin.
But when I'm thinking about foreskin
that just that's a crazy sentence to
say. Um I'm thinking about the Jewish
traditions and all that the the uh
circumcision. And so there's like a
Jewish connection here. I know she said
Korea or something like that, but but
keep that in your mind. We're talking
about blood consumption. We're talking
about for skins. We're talking about
reversing aging and all this stuff. And
we're talking about Hollywood. We're
talking about the entertainment
industry. How does it all connect? Like,
I I really thought that I was just going
to cover this in in 30 minutes and be
like, look at this scientific article
and look at how these uh elites are
aging backwards. That's crazy. And
here's a Bible verse and end it. But
this rabbit hole goes so far down that
this would be like a five hour show if I
was really gonna cover what me and
Aubrey just like found out. Like this is
mind-blowing.
You guys have probably seen some of this
stuff before. This is Lady Gaga with
Marina. Marina I can't remember her
name. I'll I'll see it here in a second.
But uh they're doing the spirit cooking
ritual where there's these cakes that
look like dead bodies and they're
consuming the blood. Why would they be
doing this? What sane person in their
right mind would be doing these kinds of
acts? And yet it's always the Hollywood
elites. Those are the crazy people that
are doing it. And and this lady is
openly performing Alistister Crowley
ritual magic cooking called spirit
cooking. We're going to prove that. Oh
yeah, this was another one. Uh Christina
Aguilera. This this over here was 2001
and this is 2024.
I mean, it literally looks like they
were shot the same day. I mean, there's
you can't even tell the difference.
There's she's supposedly 23 years older
over here on the right. Something's
going on, man. Some ma magic voodoo is
is happening. So, this is the word that
I didn't want to say because this video
might get pulled just for having this
word on screen. Who knows? But it's a a
biological on the biological side. What
it is is an oxida the oxidation of
adrenaline in the blood. When a person
is under extreme terror or trauma, the
blood floods with adrenaline. If blood
is drawn at the peak moment, it contains
high levels of this oxidized substance.
So when people go through SRRA, satanic
ritual abuse, this is not a conspiracy
theory. This is real life. This has been
going on since the Bible days when
people were sacrificing their babies to
Moolok and setting their own child on
the red burning hot hands of Moolok and
they're throwing their babies in the
river to the crocodiles. Like this is
nothing new. These Satanists will put
children through trauma so that their
blood gets filled with this oxidized
adrenaline. And when that substance that
I'm not going to say the name of is
ingested, you reach a high. It's like
it's like a drug. And in the movie Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas, he actually
talks about that he wants to do this
drug. And he says, "Just give me a
little adrenal gland and I'll chew on it
and all this stuff." And they're doing
every drug there is while he's writing
this book. Now, on the occult side, it
says the elites don't just want blood.
They want terrified blood. They believe
drinking it or using it ritually gives
vitality, heightened awareness and
contact with spirit realms. This is
satanic ritual stuff. Ancient roots of
fear blood rituals. Canaanite and
Phoenician sacrifice. This goes back to
Baal and Moolok. Children were passed
through the fire, the Bible said to
Moolok, but not always burned outright.
Some were tortured, mutilated, or
frightened first, then offered. Priests
of Baal believed the energy of the
child's terror combined with blood was
more potent in summoning and pleasing
their gods. So it was often a common
ritual that people would make a
sacrifice, a human sacrifice to their
god to appease the gods, to be blessed
by the gods, right? God never required a
human sacrifice. He sent his he sent his
own son. Christ came willfully to die as
the final sacrifice for humanity. But
God never asked for a human sacrifice
ever. That was only Satan. Aztec and
Mayans. We're going around the world
here. Aztec and Mayan human sacrifice.
Victim heart victim's hearts were cut
out while still beating. Maximum
adrenaline state. I've seen this like in
movies and stuff where these minds will
literally do that. I think it happened
in uh Indiana Jones or something like
that. Blood was smeared or consumed by
priests who claimed it maintained the
cosmos and their and their own power.
Egyptian and Babylon initiates drank red
elixir and temples and temple rights
writings hint these were not just wine
but mixtures of blood. Babylonian texts
describe life from blood especially from
young captives. The Bible literally says
the life is in the blood. That's why
these people are consuming it. But we
were we were always told not to consume
blood. And yet Satan, he's trying
everything he can to offer eternal life.
He's trying to counterfeit everything
that God can give. God's the only one
that can give. He's trying to
counterfeit it.
Greek mystery cults. Dionician rights
involve frenzy, terror, and even tearing
animals, sometimes humans, apart to
consume their raw flesh and blood called
omafagia.
Again, adrenaline soaked flesh and blood
perceived equals perceived power.
This word, I don't know if I should say
it either, but this word right here, the
blood, that word, um, this video will
probably get taken down because of,
believe it or not, race, racism, uh,
anti-semitism, things like that, because
it says the infamous that word
accusations,
medieval Europe claimed Jews kidnapped
Christian children, drained their blood,
and used it for rituals or Passover
bread. Remember how I said there's a
connection, right? Blood, foreskin,
Hollywood,
entertainment industry, and these guys,
the Jews.
Truth versus propaganda. Many of these
accusations were weaponized lies to stir
up hatred and persecution. However, it's
important to see why this rumor
persisted, right? I don't think these
rumors just magically appeared for no
reason. because it reflected something
real happening in the occult
underground. Not specifically tied to to
the Jewish people as a whole. This is
not just like if you're born Jew, you're
Jewish descent, that you are an
occultist, but there is a sector of the
Jewish religion called the Cabala. So
hidden practices, secret societies, co
cobalistic offshoots and mystery cults
were practicing ritual blood consumption
in Europe, often scapegoating others
when whispers spread. The conspiracy of
children, fear, and blood being tied
together across cultures, suggest some
groups really were doing it. Of course,
these these aren't just madeup fairy
tales, even if the official accusations
were misdirected. Uh, so I'm not going
to read all this. Wow, there's a lot
there. But I remember seeing a a video
of some Jewish guy crawling out of the
sewer, a manhole in New York, and
everybody was saying when they went down
there, there was like these blood soaked
mattresses and stuff. Like, there is
stuff going on. Like, don't bury your
head in the sand and think that that all
of this is just a big conspiracy theory.
So, this makes me think of what we just
read about this substance, about
adrenaline and fear and all this stuff
makes me think of the movie Monsters,
Inc. by Disney. Of course, Disney Pixar.
Just think rationally about this. A
familyfriendly cartoon production Disney
Pixar puts out a movie about these
friendly demons that go into your
children's room and scare them and they
use the fear as energy. Check it out.
Here's a summary of the plot of Monsters
Inc. including spoilers because I asked
it to give me spoilers. It says,
"Monstropolis
is a city of monsters or demons powered
by the screams of human children."
Are you kidding me? Mind-blowing. This
is what we just read. Monsters, Inc. is
a company tasked with collecting these
screams. Skilled scarers like Sully and
Mike enter the human world through
closet doors that act as portals to the
children's bedroom. Like this is such a
the the language of this is so
spiritual. Demons come through portals,
open doorways that we allow demons into
our life by opening doors, right? Doors
and portals. By messing around with
stuff we shouldn't be messing around
with. They scare the children and their
screams are captured in specialized
canisters to power the monster world, to
power the demon world. Demons are
powered by fear. the fear of children.
And so when these people make a deal
with the devil for fame and fortune and
uh eternal youth, they are being powered
or rejuvenated by the fear of children.
Just like this movie said. Why is it in
a movie? Because it's the revelation of
the method predictive programming right
here. putting it in your face because
when when Satan puts it in your face
then he has access because when you
openly are entertained by it like oh I
love Monsters Inc. Well, guess what?
You're literally saying, "I love this
ritual of fear, like scaring children,
demons, terrifying children, and using
their fear as energy." When you're
entertained by that, when you take
pleasure in that, you're opening a door
for the for demonic presences to come
into your life. Think about how crazy
that is. We're so deceived by everything
that we're putting in front of our
faces, that we're putting in our ears.
And I mean, it's just it's mind-blowing
to me because I was so deceived growing
up. I listened to Marilyn Manson
non-stop. Antichrist Superstar was my
favorite album. And I'd go to sleep
every night with that on repeat on the
CD player. Marina Abramovic, the elite
entertainers of this world, idolize this
woman for some reason. Jay-Z, Lady Gaga,
Gwen Stefani, who's now pushing the uh
Hallow app, the prayer app. They all
love this woman. And here she is. But
this is what she considers art writing
in blood on the walls things like mix
fresh breast milk with fresh sperm milk
on the earthquake nights. What does this
come from? This is the sacrament in the
religion of phal lima which was founded
by Alistister Crowley. This is a
Alistister Crowley ritual about making
these cakes with all kinds of disgusting
human fluids in it. Why? To summon
demons to get powers from the spirit
world. And here she is painting blood on
a very small person, a child most
likely, right? shaped like a small
child. Why? Why? Why would this be
considered art? And here she is with
Jay-Z.
Why? Now you know why Jay-Z is so
satanic. Now you realize who he idolizes
and who he's working with. People like
this. Vogue magazine even has her with
her hands on a child both wearing red.
This is not a coincidence.
And oh, she's holding a severed goat
head. That that's artistic, you know.
It's a Don't look too deep into it. It's
just art. Um, here she is. What is going
on here? Somebody a dismembered body is
also in the magazine. A serpent covering
one eye. Just a artsy photograph in the
Vogue magazine. No connection here.
Don't don't dig too deep, guys. Don't
don't just make assumptions. Look, art
project again covering one eye. Uh this
is this woman is completely satanic,
completely twisted and even her name is
Abramovic M666
and somebody asked her about it and
she's like yeah why not you know she
responded to that. Um so I asked Google
what is the sacrament in the religion of
the Lima and it says in the Lima a
sacrament is a ritual act believed to
have spiritual significance. The most
prominent sacrament is the cake of light
which is used in the Gnostic mass. This
is so crazy and other rituals. It's a
cake made with flour, honey, oils, and
sometimes bodily fluids like semen or
minstal blood. This sacrament is
believed to facilitate spiritual
transformation
and connection with the divine.
So this is what Alist the Ph the Limma
is a religion that Alistister Crowley
created and he was constantly
communicating with demons. He called
himself the wickedest man alive. He was
a pedo. I mean he was the sickest person
alive and yet the Beatles put him on
their album cover. Jay-Z writes his
slogan do what thou wilt on his hoodie.
Like why are so many people connected?
when Azie Osborne had that song, Mr.
Crowley, why are so many people in the
Hollywood or in the entertainment
industry obsessed with Alistister
Crowley with blood, with uh witchcraft
and magic and all that stuff because
they sold out. They sold their souls to
the god of this world who says, "I can
give you all the kingdoms of the world
if you'll just bow down to me." But what
profits a man to gain the whole world
and lose his very soul? Yeah, this this
cannibalism stuff going on. This is
really what's going on at this party
that they're attending. Uh who is this?
Is that
Oh, Blondie. The lead singer of Blondie
was there.
Uh what's up with this? Why you got this
kid? You're covering his eyes and he's
not even clothed. I mean, this is sick
sick stuff. And yet these people are
idolizing this woman
apparently for about 10 years now. I'd
never even heard of this show. There's
some show like a reality show with
celebrities. It's called I'm a Celebrity
and they're taking part in some very
satanic ritualistic type stuff. Warning,
this is
crazy.
Notice the floor. I'm not even going to
say anything about it. Just pay
attention to the floor.
That's literal blood, just so you know.
And there's about to be chunks of flesh
coming down. But you you see the floor.
You see what the pattern on the floor
is, right?
That's not a coincidence. That has
meaning.
If you don't know, just look up the
Masonic apron and you will see that the
Masons are all about this checkered
floor which is now covered in blood. I
mean, this is this is insane. And we
call this entertainment. Do you see how
sick and debased society is right now
that we have like 10 people in baths of
blood on a checkered floor and this is
entertainment? Another one of the
episodes
was they were spinning the bottle to see
who was gonna have to do whatever the
dare was. I guess
>> that is Gordo.
>> I don't want to know what it is.
>> It's deer's blood.
>> It blood li.
Oh, you looking animal?
>> Since when did satanic rituals become
entertainment? Do you guys remember when
there was this skit about friendlies and
these people are all eating ice cream
and out of nowhere I don't know what I
don't know what the funny part is. Show
me what the funny part is. They're all
ordering their ice cream and then
suddenly the walls open up and everybody
they bring out a snake. They're wearing
red cloaks and they're talking about how
they're they're gonna abduct the girl
here and make her heart the ice cream
for all the friends to eat. That's
funny. That's Saturday Night Live. Look
at these guys with pentagrams and horns.
This is a Saturday Night Live skit
that's supposed to be funny. And that's
Lady Gaga wearing the red cloak.
What What part of this is funny? Where's
the humor in this?
I mean, this is where we're at in in
society today. The revelation of the
method. They're putting it out in front
of your face, the predictive
programming. And yet, we are still just
like, "No, whatever. This is just
comedy. It's just art." And again,
there's a checkered floor right here in
the background where the skull is. This
is a an elaborate set. I mean, it took
money to build a set like this,
put her in a cage, they ripped the heart
out. We just saw that. That That's
the I'm trying to not say the word. The
adrenaline with the Google Chrome put
together.
This is how you get it, right? They said
they rip out the beating heart. They did
this. The minds did this.
And so, where's the connection? What?
What's What is this? We got Hollywood.
We got entertainment. We got the
foreskin on your face with Sandra
Bulock. We got uh the eternal youth and
and the elites who want to live forever
and they worship Satan and all this
stuff. And it's interesting that we have
these what they call the black hats. I
don't even know what kind of words I can
say without getting flagged or whatever.
these white dudes with beards and curly
locks and these black hats and they're
always meeting up with the presidents
and the the rulers of the world. I don't
know what the significance would be for
this unless they play some kind of big
role. These cabalist
that play a big role in our world today.
Um this is what an Israeli person looks
like. I don't know who these white dudes
are with the black hats, but they don't
seem like Jews to me in the sense of the
bloodline of the Jews. They have this
flag with this hexog on it. This is the
the Jewish flag, the Israeli flag. This
is not a Star of David. We should not be
saying, "I stand with Israel and and
you're flying this hexog." What does
that symbol actually mean when you look
it up? In the occult esoteric
traditions, a hexog, a six-pointed star
formed by two overlapping equilateral
triangles, is a potent symbol often
associated with the union of opposites.
That would be the yin and the yang, the
good and evil put together. Um, the
opposites, spiritual and material
realms, and the hermetic principle, as
above, so below. That's why it's a
triangle up and a triangle down overlaid
as above so below. It is used in various
magical practices including ceremonial
magic and is attributed is attributed to
the seven classical planets in
astrology.
So this is cab C cabalism when you see
these celebrities wearing the red string
on their wrist. Justin Bieber, Madonna,
Leonardo DiCaprio, all wearing this red
thread on their wrist. This is them
telling you, "I'm a cobbalist." But
they're not openly telling you. They're
subtly telling you. This is the
revelation of the method. They have to
subtly tell you or else, you know,
they're not basically they are showing
you who they give their allegiance to.
When they throw up the horns, when they
throw up the 666 over their eyes, when
they wear this red thread, it's just
like a Christian wearing a t-shirt that
says, "I love Jesus." They're giving
their allegiance to their master. And
this is that word that I don't want to
say because I think this will actually
get this video pulled down. And it says,
"This word is a false or uh malicious
accusation that falsely accuses Jews of
murdering Christians to use their blood
for religious rituals. This anti-semitic
trope has been a reoccurring theme
throughout history, often used to incite
violence and discrimination against
Jewish communities." Says the accusation
is a fabrication lacking any factual
basis. Why do they say that? How can you
just say there's no facts behind this
when you look up images and you'll see
this like ancient art of
of these people uh putting straws into
children and drinking their blood. Like
this is crazy to just think, oh, there's
no factual basis for any of this stuff.
It's just uh it's just racism is all it
is. Um, no. I think there's some truth
to this. There's there's sculptures.
It's not just artwork like that. There
are literal sculptures that are showing
the same thing happening.
And who was it that killed Christ? The
Jews, right? Who was it that were going
after the disciples? When you read the
Bible, it says that they were hiding for
fear of the Jews. KJV online. They were
Christians, right? They were followers
of Christ. And the Jews hated Christ
because they thought he was the false
Messiah. They're still waiting on the
Messiah. For fear, how be it, no man
spake openly of him for fear of the
Jews. Why were these people fearful of
the Jews?
I think there might be some truth to
some of these ancient artworks. All
right. Now, the same day at evening when
being the first day of the week when the
doors were shut where the where the
disciples were assembled for fear of the
Jews. For fear of the Jews. Why? They
were Christians. And yet we hear that
this word is some anti-semitic trope
that's really uh like racism against
Jewish people. that there is really no
no truth to the fact that they murdered
Christian people. What happened to all
the disciples? They were crucified by
who? By the Jews.
Now, check this out. This is this is LA
Times. This is not a conspiracy theory
website. LA Times would be the furthest
thing from a conspiracy theory website.
And it says, "Who runs Hollywood? Come
on." And it says, "I've never been so
upset by a poll in all my life. Only 22%
of Americans now believe the movie and
television industry are pretty much run
by Jews. That's down from nearly 50% in
1964. The Anti-Defamation League, which
released the poll results last month,
sees in these numbers a victory against
stereotyping. Actually, it just shows
how dumb America has gotten. Jews
totally run Hollywood. I mean, this is
this is so in your face. This is not a
conspiracy website. This is LA Times. LA
is right there in the belly of the
beast, right there in Babylon. And
they're saying that people are basically
just afraid to admit that Hollywood is
run by Jews because they're afraid of
being called uh anti-semitic or
stereotypers, right? But back in 1964,
50% of people knew that. Oh man, where
did it say they basically own
everything? Look at this.
When the studio chiefs took out a full
page ad in the Los Angeles Times a few
weeks ago to demand that the Screen
Actors Guild settle its contract, the
open letter was signed by News Corp.
President Peter Shernan, Jewish,
Paramount Pictures chairman Brad Gray,
Jewish. Walt Disney Company chief
executive Robert Iger, Jewish. Sony
Pictures chairman Michael Linton
surprised Dutch Jew. Okay, you get the
point. All of them. All of them.
Hollywood is run by Jews. So the
entertainment industry is run by these
cobalists. Remember I don't think these
are Jews. These are cobbalists that run
the world. They run the entertainment
industry. Why are the entertainment
industry so obsessed with Satanism,
blood consumption, eternal youth, all
this stuff, idolizing yourself, pride
and everything, right? Because they're
workers of Satan.
It says right here in the department,
this is this is state.gov, the US
Department of State defining
anti-semitism.
There are laws
against
speaking out against these cobalists,
these Satanists. And it says that it's
actually a a criminal act. Look at this.
Criminal acts are anti-semitic when the
target of attacks, whether they are
people or property such as buildings,
schools, places of worship, or
cemeteries, are selected because they
are or are perceived to be Jewish or
linked to Jews. says right here,
anti-semitism are anti-semitics
acts are criminal when they are so
defined by a law, for example, denial of
the Holocaust or distribution of
anti-semitic materials in some
countries. I think this right here, this
video would be considered anti-semitic
material when we're just giving you the
truth, the candid truth. Straight
straight up anti-semitic discrimination.
I don't think anybody should be
discriminated against. But I'm saying
what other
race or uh nationality or belief system
is so protected that there are laws
against it. Laws like if you make fun of
this community, you will go to jail or
be fined or something. This is a
government website.
And yet Marilyn Manson can rip out pages
of the Bible. Like I said, I used to be
obsessed with this guy. He can rip out
pages of the Bible and it's not a hate
crime. He can do it publicly over and
over and over. This guy did this all the
time. Ripping out pages of the Bible. Uh
people defame Christ, blaspheme God,
mock Christians all day, every day in
Hollywood. Why? Because they're coalist.
They hate Christ. They nailed him to a
cross. They killed the Christians. They
killed those that followed him on a
cross upside down. Behead them, put them
in oil, exile them to an island. That's
how these satanic cobbists treat
Christians.
What does Revelation say? Revelation 3:9
says, "Behold, I will make them of the
synagogue of Satan, which say they are
Jews and are not, but do lie. Behold, I
will make them to come and worship
before thy feet, and to know that I have
loved thee. So, the Bible talks about a
group of people who say they are Jews,
but are not. And they are the synagogue
of Satan. They're the cobbalist that
control the world that brainwash you
with the entertainment industry that
make you worship and idolize demon
demonpossessed
bloodrinkers.
I mean it it's so insane when you really
look at the truth of what's going on in
our world and we talk about all this to
say this. We are in a dark, twisted time
like the days of Noah, like the days of
Sodom and Gomorrah. And what did Jesus
say? He said, "It'll be as in the days
of Noah and in the days of Lot." And
people think like we're not there yet.
Oh man, we are so there on so many
levels. I believe that Jesus is coming
soon. But before he does, Satan is going
to appear as a supernatural spiritual
being doing lying signs and wonders and
performing miracles. And so many
Christians are going to fall for this
deception because it's going to look so
close to the truth that they're going to
fall for their senses. I saw him heal
that person. I felt the love in my
heart. I was He's such a beautiful
being. It has to be Jesus.
Satan is coming out so open right now so
that it'll be so clear how wicked the
world is that the world is crying out
for a savior. This world is so twisted
and sick. We need a savior. And guess
what? Satan will come as that savior.
And millions will be deceived because
we're not reading the book of Revelation
that says, "Blessed are those who read
this book and keep the words that are in
this book and hear this the words that
are in this book." We're not
understanding prophecy and therefore
we're setting ourselves up to be
deceived by the Antichrist that is soon
to come. If this is new to you guys,
please subscribe to this channel. Please
watch some of the other videos that we
we've been putting out lately because
science is also telling us that aliens
are going to be here in November. You
know, science is now saying that uh baby
blood can can keep you from aging. Like
everything is coming out right now. The
stage is being set. The externalization
of the hierarchy, all these things. If
you're new to this channel, please
subscribe if you were blessed by this.
If you were had your eyes open anyway,
please give this video a thumbs up. It
really helps get this video out into the
algorithm so more people can see this so
they can see the truth. And give us a
comment. We read all your comments. We
want to know what you think. If you got
a little more input, give us some more
details. We want to know what you're
finding out, what you're seeing. If you
want to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to candidruth.org.
We got Cash App, Vinmo, Zel. We also
have PayPal and Patreon. We cannot thank
you guys enough. We can only do this
because of you. We are a donated a
donorup supported ministry. We can only
do this with you. And we thank you. We
love you. And we'll see you next time on
Can of Truth.